[Music]
on this sunday night game over for novak
djokovic the unvaccinated tennis star is
deported from australia
after losing his bid to stay and play
what it means for the world number one
not only does he end up on the losing
end of the draw at the australian open
but i don't think he does anything for
his public image
canada's covet rules what's behind the
growing calls to scrap on arrival
testing at canadian airports plus the
search for victims of the deadly
explosion in ottawa many people are
working together day and night
to make sure that we find your loved
ones why the investigation is proving so
challenging and a banner year off bc's
coast i think the message is that we
have a lot to be hopeful for a spike in
sightings and a baby boom fuel hope for
whale populations in the pacific
global national reporting tonight
colleen christie
good evening thanks for joining us after
days of dramatic back and forth tonight
the australian open is getting underway
without its defending men's champion
novak djokovic has been deported after
losing his last ditch appeal to stay in
the country eric sorenson has tonight's
top story on the final ruling and
reaction to it
it was the final frenzy for the world's
top tennis player australia's federal
court sealed his fate the orders of the
court are one
the amended application be dismissed
novak djokovic dismissed from the
australian open and from the country
without delay he headed for the airport
issuing a statement i am extremely
disappointed with the court ruling to
dismiss my application
outside court djokovic supporters fell
silent
it's a political stunt
this is this is yourself
the court's chief justice said he was
not ruling on the merits of the
government decision to revoke djokovic's
visa only on its legality the government
required visitors without a valid
medical exemption to be fully vaccinated
djokovic was not that is the policy that
policy hasn't changed on the court
ruling the prime minister stated i
welcome the decision to keep our borders
strong and keep australians safe i don't
think it's fear that he'd be allowed to
come in to be honest so i think it's the
right decision the world number one has
been booted out of australia the
controversy riled up a global audience
including his fans and anti-vaxx
proponents for whom djokovic is a hero
he was sending out a wide array of
messages to the anti-vaxx people
by his
mere refusal to say anything yeah over
here looking over here others saw
djokovic using his lofty status as a
sports celebrity to undercut life-saving
public health policies while skirting
the rules himself he's a role model not
only does he end up on the losing end of
the draw at the australian open but i
don't think he does anything for his
public image moving forward either
djokovic was the number one seed for the
australian open his departure a big loss
new names will be favored now from
russia and germany and two canadians are
also highly ranked contenders rafael
nadal wants to focus on tennis not
djokovic australian open will be a great
australian open
with or without him the tournament is
underway this evening but for the world
number one it was as they say an early
exit from the australian open eric
sorensen global news toronto
getting a covet 19 pcr test in canada
can be challenging even when you have
symptoms fueling the debate over its
value for asymptomatic travelers
returning to the country the on arrival
pcr test requirement was put in place by
the federal government in hopes of
slowing the spread of the omicron
variant but now that it's ripping
through canada calls are growing louder
to scrap the policy as tests overwhelm
the system abigail beeman reports we're
stuck stuck in quarantine waiting for
arrival test results nine days after
returning from a christmas trip to see
grandparents what are we spending the
money on what are we expending the
resources on it's a question more and
more people are asking with testing
capacity stretched and some symptomatic
people unable to get a pcr test while
returning travelers already have a
negative one taken within 72 hours of
arrival except for a small spike at
christmas traveler test positivity rates
hover around 1 percent and often less
while community positivity rates are now
at 28 percent much better to direct
those pcr
testing and the things available at
airports to population testing we're
kind of flying blind to try to keep
flyers to get them tested tracking every
case isn't
you know really necessary for a
surveillance perspective canada's top
doctor says testing a sample of
returning travelers may be a better way
to go it is a capacity
[Music]
drain on the systems as a whole while
the health minister refuted that in an
interview on the west block those
resources that we're using at the
borders to protect canadians and to
protect people traveling through the
borders those resources are different
from the resources that providence and
territories have access to they use
their own resources we use our own
resources the president of the canadian
chamber of commerce isn't buying that
given the overall backlog at labs when
all that you have is a hammer
everything looks like a nail
and to be seen to be doing something has
been focusing on the border instead of
saying rationally how should we be using
our resources the chamber of commerce is
part of the canadian travel and tourism
roundtable which this week called for an
end to on arrival pcr tests dr tam
didn't go so far as to recommend that
but said she would advise against using
resources to sequence every traveler
test given omicron is so prevalent
everywhere abigail beeman global news
ottawa
after a punishing fourth wave fueled by
the delta variant alberta and
saskatchewan are now grappling with the
effects of omicron in both provinces
hospital beds are filling up as both
governments continue to resist hard line
restrictions heather urex west looks at
what the strategy could mean as the
fifth wave builds
throughout the omicron-fueled fifth wave
saskatchewan has been an outlier there
were no gathering limits over christmas
and when the break ended students
returned to school in person as
scheduled but even as hospital numbers
in the province begin to once again rise
the premier is steadfast with his
approach as we
look at at you know public health
restrictions that would be put in place
that ultimately would limit
you know people from from coming
together whether that be in schools
whether that be in workplaces in our
community
there it doesn't seem to be slowing the
spread of omicron in other areas of
canada gathering restrictions the
premier argued wednesday don't seem to
work i actually don't know
what
empirical data that he has
to
back up that claim but this
epidemiologist worries saskatchewan is
once again heading for trouble
while the number of patients in
intensive care units have fallen in
recent weeks non-icu patient numbers are
on the rise so we are about halfway
through
into this into this wave
we are seeing 125 hospital beds occupied
and i think it could easily be doubling
and tripling you know from from that
point on the virus spreading so quickly
the premier himself announced thursday
he tested positive as well this is the
highest number of active cases that we
have identified in alberta at any time
during kovitt with more than 60 thousand
active cases alberta is also now seeing
hospital numbers rise but with pcr tests
now unavailable to most people with
symptoms and rapid tests impossible to
find the actual case count in the
province is likely much higher with more
still to come we're not even
seeing the cases that were caused by the
gatherings at christmas or
new year's yet so the odds are things
are going to get significantly worse but
like scott moe jason kenny is resisting
calls to implement new restrictions
hoping instead that the omicron wave
will peak and fade away before hospitals
become overwhelmed heather urex west
global news calgary
an update tonight on the investigation
into the deadly explosion at an
industrial business in ottawa officials
say the remains of four people killed in
the blast have been found but not yet
recovered so far the investigation has
been difficult
the cold
the sight conditions the size of the
area
and the magnitude of the blast
have created challenges that we are
continuing
to deal with and overcome
investigators now face an additional
challenge a snowstorm expected to hit
the ottawa area tonight the five people
missing and presumed dead will not
officially be identified until remains
are recovered
the federal government is urging
canadians to avoid non-essential travel
to ukraine late saturday canada updated
its advisory citing ongoing russian
aggression and military buildup in and
around the country western governments
have strongly condemned russia's buildup
of soldiers and weaponry along its
border with ukraine
foreign minister melanie jolie was
headed to kiev today to meet with
ukrainian officials and show canada's
support
new details are emerging about
yesterday's hostage taking at a texas
synagogue authorities have identified
the suspect as a 44-year-old british
national he was killed after the
standoff that lasted more than 10 hours
the four people taken hostage were
safely rescued jennifer johnson reports
on the investigation and what's known
about the motive
the rabbi at the congregation beth
israel was conducting a saturday morning
service when the suspect stormed in some
congregants listened to the hostage
taking unfold from home on a facebook
live stream the suspect was heard
demanding the release of pakistani
neuroscientist afiyah sadiki convicted
of trying to kill two u.s army officers
in afghanistan in 2008 i do not have any
information right now that indicates
that this is part of any kind of ongoing
threat we obviously are investigating
our investigation will have global reach
local police learned about the hostage
situation after the rabbi called another
rabbi in new york negotiations went on
for hours one hostage was eventually
released later the fbi breached the
building rescuing the others and killing
the suspect he has been identified as 44
year old british national malik faisal
akram this is something that you don't
ever expect to have in your own city
the rabbi is a personal friend of mine
during the terrifying ordeal members of
the local muslim community came to show
their support to the congregation to say
our jewish
brother that we are behind them and
we fully support them and against this
condemn this
act president joe biden called this an
act of terror i wanted to make sure we
got the word out to
synagogues and places of worship that
we're not going to tolerate this while
the captor first described siddiqui as
his muslim sister they were not related
siddiki educated in the u.s is serving
an 86-year prison term at a federal
detention center in fort worth her
arrest and conviction is widely
criticized in pakistan where she is seen
as being wrongfully imprisoned the fbi
says it is already in contact with
agents in london and tel aviv to make
sure the suspect was not working with
anyone overseas
jennifer johnson global news washington
there are reports of significant damage
in tonga after an underwater volcano
erupted triggering tsunami warnings
new video shows beachside towns in tonga
battered moments after the blast at this
stage there are no reports of deaths
though telephone and internet
connections are cut off australia and
new zealand say they're standing by to
send help
the tsunami has had a significant impact
shops along the coast have been damaged
and a significant cleanup will be needed
and the eruptions sent shockwaves across
the pacific ocean flooding coastal
cities as far away as peru
coming up what a nearly two-year school
closure could mean for the future of one
nation's students
students in four provinces are set to
return to in-person learning tomorrow
after the latest pandemic wave forced an
extended holiday break but imagine
children and teachers in uganda who only
returned to the classroom last week the
first time since march 2020. the united
nations says it's the world's longest
shutdown and as redmond shannon reports
many students will never return
a brand new school term in uganda
eagerly awaited by students teachers and
parents like patrick samanda
of course it's difficult
for a parent to be tutoring their own
child then you go to work
and then when you leave them assignments
they don't get do anything at all for
almost two years since the start of the
pandemic ugandan schools have been fully
or partially shut the government wanted
to keep them closed until covert 19
vaccination rates increased a quarter of
ugandans have now had a vaccine only
three percent are double jabbed but
authorities decided enough is enough
it's been really really hard even when
you tried we tried to do private
tutoring for these kids we didn't know
for which classes are we tutoring them
for so
it's been very complicated it's been
very hard only a small minority of
ugandans have the technology to learn
online the government estimates a third
of students will never
return students like sarah only 16 and
already a mother herself
she says had she been busy with school
she probably wouldn't have ended up in a
relationship with an older man where she
got pregnant
an old blackboard on a building that was
once a school but no more this was a
classroom
but it ended up into
a what a rental house
teachers may be lost too about half of
ugandan schools are privately run many
of those educators forced to get work
elsewhere
i hope that this time there is no clue
again
let us manage these situations as they
come from schools and then life
continues like that like every country
uganda's economy has been hit hard
poverty has only increased uganda is
already one of the poorest countries in
the world
i would say unicef would not have
advised for this kind of measure there
are different measures to prevent the
spread of infection through the
education system the shock of the
pandemic to uganda's education system
will have long-term effects on people's
lives and on the future of a country
that can least afford it redmond shannon
global news london
i had the life sentence seen as a
victory for thousands of syrians
you're watching global national
a former syrian colonel has begun a life
sentence for crimes against humanity
anwar r was convicted for his role in
supervising the torture rape and murder
of detained individuals suspected of
being anti-bashar al-assad demonstrators
as crystal gomezing reports the german
criminal court is the first to
acknowledge the crimes committed by the
regime
his face must be obscured but his role
in the torture and murder of syrians has
now been revealed anwar are was
sentenced to life in prison friday after
being convicted of murder grievous
bodily harm sexual assault deprivation
of liberty and hostage taking crimes
committed when he was an intelligence
officer and oversaw the interrogation
unit at a notorious detention center
court officials said the al qaeda prison
also known as hell on earth held roughly
4 000 people when he worked there this
trial cast a much-needed renewed
spotlight on the kinds of sickening
torture cruel and truly inhuman
treatment including abject sexual
violence that countless syrians were
subjected to in detention facilities
the trial which began in 2020 included
difficult and detailed testimony from
victims
before this conviction the same court
already convicted a second junior syrian
officer of accessory to crimes against
humanity
both men had come to germany seeking
asylum years ago but were arrested in
2019. it's a recognition of the crimes
committed in syria
and i think it's quite okay for the
survivor the syrian who are uh
affected with this crime
so i hope that
this sentence and this verdict will be a
strong pace for future work
the german criminal court is the first
to try a case against any member of the
syrian regime under the idea of
universal justice cases like this are
usually heard in the international court
in the hague but experts say russia and
china have blocked efforts to try cases
like this there it is a landmark leap
forward in the pursuit of truth justice
and reparations for the serious human
rights violations perpetrated in syria
human rights abuses in syria at the
hands of the regime have been well
documented the civil war which began in
2011 as a part of the arab spring led to
what human rights groups call the
world's largest refugee crisis
canada at the time pledged to take 25
thousand refugees sahir who helped
during operation syrian refugee says the
case serves as a reminder you know it is
great news of course it's an opportunity
for justice it's an opportunity to start
some healing potentially
but for me personally it was just a
reminder of the fact that we let
these crimes against humanity happen in
the first place as an international
community
for those who lost loved ones they want
the world to remember their faces but
also know that lives are still being
lost the war is not over yet
crystal gomencing global news london
big baby boom
next the rebound of whales off canada's
west coast
when we look after the environment
nature often rewards us that appears to
be the case off canada's west coast
where a whale baby boom is taking place
two whale species are making a big
comeback katherine ercart shows us
what's behind the rebound
they're some of the most majestic
mammals on earth biggs killer whales are
also known as transient whales and
according to the pacific whale watch
association 2021 was a great year for
that orca population which had record
sightings and experienced a baby boom i
think the message is that we have a lot
to be hopeful for
[Music]
sightings of biggs killer whales
surpassed 1000 in 2021 and their
population of less than 400 had 11
calves last year
migrating humpback whales also saw a
baby boom with the birth of 21 calves in
2020 we thought that was a great year
with 11 calves and so with 21 that's
almost double
the year before so humpbacks are just
like the bigs
experiencing a lot of population growth
marine mammal protections are making all
the difference says the pacific whale
watch association humpbacks are thriving
because commercial whaling was stopped
biggs killer whales are succeeding due
to protection of their food sources such
as seals and sea lions but the truth is
because we do have all these protections
in place and there's so much more
education out there we are seeing
animals return
not doing so well our southern resident
killer whales which almost exclusively
eat salmon
their population estimated at just 74
but conservationists remain hopeful that
one day they too will thrive like the
humpbacks and the biggs killer whales
katherine ercart global news
and that is global national for this
sunday night i'm colleen christie
tonight york canada is blumenort
manitoba we would love to see your
corner of the country so please keep
sending your photos to viewers at
globalnational.com
thanks for watching donna friesen will
be back at the anchor desk tomorrow have
a good night
[Music]
you